(audience applauding)
Hi, Giada, how are you?
I'm good, darlin', how are you?
I'm so good.
You have 10 best-selling cookbooks.
10!
Well, if this one becomes a best seller,
then I'll have 10!
So I guess I only have nine so far, right?
But this is my 10th book.
So that's exciting.
I would say that this one, the die is already cast.
You already have all your books as bestsellers
and I know this one's going to be one as well,
and I really really love the whole ethos behind this book.
And would you please talk to us about it?
Well, you know, it's my wellness journey
from basically after I had my daughter Jade,
which was in my late thirties,
all the way to turning 50
which I just did earlier uh, later, last year.
So it's just, you know, I had my daughter
I had been working a lot as you might know well,
having kids, a lot of women do and we hit our forties
and unfortunately I was not bouncing back
from all of the travel and the sinus infections
that I had had and so I ended up being on antibiotics
for a couple of years and they wreaked havoc in my gut.
And I remember that the breaking point for me
was not just the being on antibiotics
but also just having to take breaks from shooting
because I couldn't be in a room with lights.
So when that started happening, I realized,
okay, I'm at a breaking point
and food is one of the biggest things that we can control
that we put in our bodies.
So I tried, I sort of went back to the way
I used to eat when I was a kid
which we had the Mediterranean diet.
So it was a much cleaner way of eating.
And so I created a three-day reboot
and then a longer sort of eating plan
where I could sort of always fall back
on that particular eating plan
to get myself feeling better again.
And it took me a long time, Drew,
almost 10 years to get there.
But I think my digestion, my immunity and my gut
is a heck of a lot better than it was
when I was in my thirties.
What you just said is so relatable.
And it was so like honest and deep, I was rapt.
Also I've have so many wellness cookbooks
and as much as I love them, I will do recipes from them.
I won't live by them cause I'm like,
"If I have to diet every day of my life
"I'm not going to make it."
Correct!
I just love food too much.
So what's so amazing about this book
is it's so good for gut flora and wellness and health
but the recipes are delicious
and you can stick with this
because the food is beautiful.
This is actual food.
You're going to eat food.
Like obviously we're going to make a pasta today
but I load them with vegetables.
Yeah. And I mean, I can't live on not eating either.
I mean, it's just, we can't do what we do
and sustain our bodies and create
good flora in our guts and all of that
if we don't eat real food.
So greens is number one and then just limiting,
try to take out as much of the processed foods as possible.
And so we can talk a little bit about that
but that's really the basics of it
but it's a lot cleaner than some of my other cookbooks.
We don't have, you know, creamy sauces.
We don't have all of that kind of stuff.
And you know I've made your cream sauce pastas.
They're my favorite-
Yeah, and they're great!
But not regularly.
Agreed, a treat if you will.
And we sent Giada's cookbook to three BFF's
who we invited to join us for Cookbook Club
and I'd love to invite them now,
please welcome Kim and Julie and Precious.
(audience applauding)
Hi, Kim and Julie and Precious!
(panel greeting)
Kim, let's start with you.
What inspired you to be a part of Cookbook Club?
I have a love of cookbooks as well as cooking.
And I was, I think I inherited the love of cookbooks
from my grandmother, who I spent a lot of time
in the kitchen with, but I also spend a lot of time
in the kitchen with my daughter when she was growing up.
And it allowed us to have that open communication.
And that's where we found out, you know
how each other's day was going on.
Generally it was, I kissed a boy today
and you wanted to know why, why now?
But it was the things that came out,
that honesty that came out
during that the kitchen time was wonderful.
Oh, I love that so much.
That's so great!
And Giada, I could see you doing that with Jade
watching all of your shows.
I feel like you guys have a beautiful journey
in the kitchen together.
We have fun the kitchen, she doesn't love to cook
the way she used to when she was younger.
But you know, I figure, give her some time.
She'll get back in there.
Julie, I hear that because of our show
your cookbook collection is growing?
Is this true?
It is, Drew that it is.
I literally ran out, after watching the segment
and bought "The Essentials of Italian Cooking."
You were just beaming when you introduced that book
and I got to have it right away.
And now I have that.
And I'm so happy that now I have Giada's
to dive into as well.
That's giving us, as you said some healthy options,
just wonderful, healthy options.
I'm all in, I'm al in.
Oh, gosh, I'm so excited,
(Drew clapping rhythmically)
that makes me so happy,
you don't even understand, Julie
because that's where my love of cooking
and food started was in cookbooks.
And Precious, welcome!
You're particularly excited about this
because you're a huge Giada fan also?
Yes. So I don't own any cookbooks, but I do love cooking
and making TikTok recipes and family recipes.
And I'm so happy because this is my first one.
And I used to watch-
Yay! (audience laughing)
Giada's program when I was in high school
"Everything Italian," and you just were so enjoyable,
you were so accessible and you make cooking really fun.
And so glad this is my first one.
I was actually hoping it was you because you're definitely
a chef I admire and Italian is just my absolute favorite.
Ah, Precious!
(Giada blows kiss)
Kim, I want to ask you, what did you love about the book,
and have you tried making a recipe yet?
I found this book to be so personable
because I related to a lot of the things
that Giada talked about.
So it just didn't really feel
like reading a cookbook at the beginning.
It was almost like reading her own personal journey.
And I thought that was fantastic.
That's so awesome!
(cheerful music)